hey youtubers is Charlie since guardians
of the galaxy is out in theaters this
week I wanted to do a review since most
of you probably have not seen the movie
yet I'm gonna do my non-spoiler review
first and then I'll get into spoilers
and since they've already confirmed the
sequel I will mention a few possible
storylines but I'm gonna do a separate
video that's gonna explore that a lot
more deeply when we do get into spoilers
I'll talk about a lot of the Easter eggs
because there are a lot of good ones
hello any new people if you're just
finding me for the first time I do
Marvel videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's a bunch of new Marvel TV shows
coming that I'm gonna be doing videos
for most of you probably at least know
who the guardians are even if you've
never read the comics the biggest
generalization you could make is Space
Avengers like a bunch of super
who come together to form a team and
keep the villains from destroying the
galaxy which galaxy you asked generally
it's assumed in this movie that it's the
Milky Way galaxy but they never say
officially most of what you've probably
been hearing about the movie is how much
everyone loves it which is kind of
surprising because the movie has just
come out a lot of the credit for that
goes to director James Gunn he directed
and wrote the script he's mostly known
for really small cult films like slither
which stars Nathan Fillion who also had
a really funny cameo in this movie done
just has a really amazing and unique
literary and visual sense that really
comes across the executives at Marvel
Studios still have a lot of say over
what stuff looks like it sounds like in
the end but the really classic Star Wars
steampunky feel that the movie has flows
from James Gunn as well as the
expression of a lot of the amazing 80s
pop culture jokes the other thing you
can think James Gunn for is the banging
awesome mixtape soundtrack
they've been marketing it as the awesome
mix number one hooked on a feelings the
song you've probably heard the most but
there's a laundry list of other classic
70s and 80s songs the Knicks tape is
just something that flows from Chris
Pratt's star-lord character the director
has a lot of influence over how
character affectations are expressed in
a movie and obviously James Gunn chose
to push that forward I think it was a
great choice so of all the things to
admire in this movie the thing you
should be most grateful for is James
Gunn and the way he treated the material
let's talk about the actors performances
a little bit because they were all
amazing but of all of them I think my
favorites were obviously Chris Pratt
Bradley Cooper and Vin Diesel the reason
I gave extra high fives to Chris Pratt
is just because of all the other actors
in the film he's the least experienced
in terms of big blockbuster movies
especially action movies and he
the lead he's on screen them oh so if he
didn't bring it the movie would totally
suck no matter how cool James got made
it look or sound trust me he will
totally get the tone of his performance
in the first five minutes he's on screen
not even that maybe like the first 30
seconds he's on screen it's amazing he
has a really great introduction Bradley
Cooper and Vin Diesel have been actually
starts for a long time so I judge them a
lot more harshly but because they're
mocap they had to do everything with
just their voice and their facial
expressions the visual effects artists
are able to control a lot of what the
character expressions are but they're
mow capped actors so essentially when
Groot and Rocket Raccoon smile or yell
it's the actors doing that they
basically the digital artists just paste
the characters on top of their faces
Bradley Cooper speaks with this really
funny brood that makes you completely
forget that he's Bradley Cooper and
allows you to just enjoy this really
funny foul-mouthed cynical raccoon and
Vin Diesel only gets three words he's
allowed to speak technically it's four
lines but really it's just three the I
am Groot I think he recorded his
dialogue in like four or five different
languages so if you go see the movie in
French or Spanish
you'll hear Vin Diesel's voice speaking
those lines in French in Spanish he
totally sells Groot but a lot of the
added fun of that character is in the
physical expressions in the way he
reacts with his face Karen Gillan was so
much fun to watch as the villain nebula
full disclosure I'm a huge Doctor Who
fan in case you just subscribed to me
and you haven't seen the billion Doctor
Who videos that I've done so I've been a
fan of hers for a long time but seeing
her play a villain who is just so much
fun like a lot of supporting character
she doesn't get a ton of screen time but
she definitely makes it count Lee pays
for all you pushing daisies and
Thranduil fans was amazing as the most
crazy villain I have ever seen in a
Marvel movie seriously no joke he is
over-the-top batshit crazy in this movie
and I totally bought it he's covered in
makeup head-to-toe so you do forget
who's underneath and he was focus on his
voice in his performance Benicio del
Toro is also one of those really amazing
secondary characters it's not on-screen
a lot but feels like a very big
character in the Marvel Universe the
collector is a really interesting
character and as ridiculous as he sounds
and looks Benicio del Toro described
himself in the movie as like a space
Liberace so you should definitely think
of his acting choices as being
completely intentional the affectations
that he brings to the character is
something that's written into that role
so he's supposed to be that way I'll
just go ahead and say that this is my
new favorite Marvel movie
it hits all the right action-movie beats
all the characters land and compared to
the other big Marvel movies like
Avengers is visually much more
interesting you'll totally be blown away
for example think about the color red
it's very very important in this movie
almost everything in the movie has this
red overcast to it and James Gunn said
that it was his reaction to the dark
brooding science fiction movies that
have come out since Blade Runner not to
say the Blade Runner was something that
he did not like it's just that he wanted
to return science fiction to the POE
penis of the 50s and 60s give it like a
much more fun feel much more optimistic
he just didn't want to give guardians
that downer feel that say like 70s
sci-fi movies like alien hat which is
also visually an amazing movie but a
total downer ending Guardians is all
about childlike Wonder and discovery
which you see mirrored in Chris Pratt's
character so if you haven't seen the
movie yet just think about the color red
when you're sitting there in the theater
I guess you could say that the color red
is also a metaphor for the influence
that Ironman has had on the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that first Ironman
film like the popularity of that
character and the irreverent tone of the
first Iron Man film has trickled down
into all other Marvel films to be fair
though red is Marvel's trademark logo
color so red has always been very
important to Marvel as a brand but
overall I give this movie a solid A+ I
think it's the only A+ I've given to any
movie this year and there were a lot of
movies that I loved this year but now
let's get into spoilers so I'm gonna
talk about specific moments and I'll
talk about some of the big Easter eggs
so careful in case you haven't seen the
movie yet I'll wait just a second
okay everybody ready here we go my
biggest surprise of the movie was how
quickly they went to Thanos and the
Infinity stones I still think of them as
infinity gems even though I just saw the
movie and I'm trying to remember Benicio
del Toro called them gems or stones I
have no idea why they feel like they
need to change little details like that
in the movies but whatever the
explainers seen that Benicio del Toro
gave on the gems is my favorite scene in
the movie it very clearly states that
super-powerful beings were not able to
contain the power of all six gems when
they were brought together did you
notice how there was no gauntlet in that
scene so clearly the big WTF surprise of
Avengers 3 is Thanos wielding all six
gems in the gauntlet I feel like the
real fun will be the way they expressed
the power of each gem on screen and
here's something weird in the movies and
in the comics
the colors of each gem are different
like the space gem the one that
teleports things is the cube that we see
in the first Avengers movie it's kind of
blueish but in the classic comics like
the fan oohs Infinity Gauntlet Story the
space gem is purple like the one we see
in the Guardians movie funny side note
in the comics tracts to destroy the
person that Batista plays in this movie
is the keeper of the power gem it's just
funny in meta it gets really confusing I
know especially when you consider that
Loki's staff contains the mind gem which
also kind of looks blueish like the
tesseract space gem I wish there were a
screencap of the movie during that del
Toro explainer scene just because they
had this really clear graphic with six
different objects just showing each of
the gems and the objects that they were
represented by so just to move on real
quickly to sequel teasers before I talk
about Easter eggs some of the biggest
we're obviously Peter Quill's father
clearly the sequels gonna explore that
then there's Thanos and the collectors
hunt for the gems that's just gonna
continue through the other Marvel films
and then there's always the possibility
of the guardians visiting earth but of
all those things I don't expect that to
happen the guardians visiting earth in
the sequel I feel like Marvel and James
Gunn will keep the guardians stories in
space it's just gonna be like their go
to space franchise obviously at some
point space has to cross over with all
the earth-based Avengers stories but I
think they're just gonna like characters
from each team moonlight I did a video a
while back about a certain Avenger maybe
being in the Guardians sequel so I'll
post a link to that in the description
there was also a spoiler this week for
the post-credits scene with Howard the
Duck just to explain that a little bit
Howard the Duck is a Marvel character
even though we haven't seen him in the
comics in a long time I feel like the
only people that will understand this
when they see the movie are people who
have seen the Howard the Duck movie or
have read the comics the reason is in
guardians is because of Gene Colan he
was the artist that originated guardians
of the galaxy and he had a hand in
working on the original Howard the Duck
comic so really it's like a comic book
Easter Egg but you could also consider
it an Easter Egg for the movie just
because of all the 80s pop culture
references that was actually a Lucasfilm
movie by the way as in Star Wars George
Lucas think of Howard the Duck it's like
the progenitor of Rocket Raccoon like
wisecracking animals hardly Duck debuted
in 1973 which did come after the
original guardians of the galaxy team
which started in 1969 but that initial
team did not feature a Rocket Raccoon
that character didn't debut until 1976
the guardians in this team like the team
makeup and the characters more closely
resemble the care
from the 2008 comic the annihilation
conquest team they rebooted the comic
again last year in 2013 so if you are
looking for guardians comics to read I
just start with the reboot it features
Iron Man joining the guardians it's
really cool it has this really funny sex
scene between him and Gamora as you
would expect Iron Man to try and have
sex with everyone in space so here are
some of the biggest Easter eggs in the
movie there's some good ones
first off Peter quill spaceship the
Milano is actually named after the
characters childhood crush Alyssa Milano
which is kind of funny remember he's the
70s and 80s pop culture junkie so a lot
of his references are frozen at the
point of where he left the earth like in
the 1980s he probably hasn't seen any
movies TV shows or music from after that
point so he has no idea who justin
bieber is imagine the disappointment
when he learns about that i thought one
of the funniest things is whenever he
called kevin bacon one of the greatest
heroes ever the legend of Footloose
inside the collectors museum there's a
ton of awesome stuff like cosmo the dog
a dark elf ash atari and a slug from
James Gunn's earlier movies slither
starring Nathan Fillion Nathan Fillion
scammy Oh in the movie is almost
unrecognizable he's that giant alien who
gets up roots branches stuck up his nose
you can kind of tell it's him by his
voice Stanley's cameo is pretty obvious
it's pretty funny whenever a rocket
racoon just calls him a total creeper
Rob Zombie had a voice only cameo as the
Navigator of yondu ship and James Gunn's
mentor Lloyd Kaufman was a prisoner
inside the kiln scenes you could
consider nowhere in easter-egg but they
did call it out verbally in the comics
people can use the brain stem of that
ancient Celestial the inside to travel
anywhere in space and time we haven't
really dealt with time-travel in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe yet though but
maybe in phase four sometime in the
future I'm not expect to get anytime
soon the opening scene is a pretty clear
brief on Raiders of the Lost Ark if only
Indy had a magnet to draw that Idol off
the trap so they're not really Easter
eggs but there are five really big
planets that they visit in the movie
that are really big in the comics too
first office Halawa creek homeworld
it debuted in the comics about the same
time Captain Marvel debuted that's
Captain Marvel not Captain Marvel
different characters
Xander is the home base of the Nova
Corps and Richard Rider the superhero
Nova James Gunn said that he kind of
hates the character so he might not make
it into the sequel he says it's just the
helmet he hates the helmet the planet
did get destroyed too
the annihilation conquest storyline
which was kind of something they alluded
to in the movie a little bit the kiln
that prison was also pretty famous
prison planet in the comics it even held
Thanos for a little while and no where I
already talked about but in the comics
Cosmo the space dog was actually the
administrator there clearly something
that James Gunn decided to change and
more like for the planet where they
found that orb was featured during a
night elation conquest it featured a
pretty epic battle between quasar and
moon dragon so just to talk about
stories for the sequel a couple
possibilities that they could draw from
include the Thanos imperative war of
kings and annihilation conquest fan OHS
imperative was a culmination of conquest
and war Kings though so they'd have to
establish Inhumans and a few other
things before dealing with the
cancerverse
and the stuff that happened during the
imperative storyline it also featured
the Infinity Gauntlet and they're not
quite there in the movies yet either
quick side note though Inhumans could be
one of those six mystery Marvel movies
that they just announced I actually
still need to do an Inhumans video at
some point pretty soon but let me know
what your favorite part of the movie was
and what story do you want to see them
do in the sequel my next Marvel video is
gonna be a guardians to video it's just
gonna go in-depth to what some of those
potential storylines are gonna be be
sure to subscribe to get it I'll try and
post it by early next week but right now
click here to learn all about the
Avengers 2 footage at Comic Con and
click here to learn all about that
Batman vs Superman footage thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you